God this is gonna happen here I think
too although maybe people will fight it
if we don't find someone who can lead us
in the right direction we could end up
like far more authoritarian States like
China for example and do you know what's
going on in China
in China for example
God this is going to happen here I think
too although maybe people will fight it
if a traffic camera catches you
jaywalking in China digital ID system
has you has your blood now has your
genetic code has your photograph it can
identify how you walk so even if you
can't see a face you can be picked up by
gate it will convict you of jaywalking
and take money out of your bank account
with no intermediating Judiciary at all
and show a picture of you to the people
in the neighborhood so they know that
you have jaywalked and reduce your
social credit score and if your social
credit score Falls below a certain level
then you can't you can't buy drinks from
a vending machine you can't play video
games you can't go on a train you can't
get out of your 15-minute City all
that's already in place in China
is that a stark enough warning like that
is literally happening in China right
now China is a highly authoritarian
State and we clearly are heading in that
direction and unless you me and
everybody else decides we are going to
put people in office who are going to
fight for our freedoms and the ideas
that America was founded upon we will
end up there too so it is up to you my
friends it really is so once again
Choose Wisely